how's it going everybody it's Warren
there is a lot of information coming out
after the fact about Avengers endgame
coming from the directors or coming from
the release of the script that has been
making its way around online right now
and today we have word about beta ray
bill somebody that we haven't heard
about in a very long time but are
expecting him to make his official MCU
debut in guardians of the galaxy vol 3
and we also have some news about
guardians vol 3 some news from James
Gunn the director of the film himself
and we also have a plot leak as well
that talks a little bit about what we
can expect from the movie now beta ray
bill has been teased of entering the MCU
for some time now and there was even the
easter-egg of him and thor ragnarok on
the tower now whether that statue was
actually him is a debate but it was
definitely a korbinite and if that
wasn't enough evidence that beta ray
bill definitely exists in the MCU Marvel
has just confirmed that we've actually
seen the korbinites in the MCU before in
fact they were in Avengers endgame so
let's talk about this beta ray bill
Easter Egg and Avengers in game talk
about what James Gunn has recently said
about the script of guardians 3 and
talked about the plot leaked don't
forget to subscribe with notifications
turned on like and comment on the video
so you can enter my giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 now I
gotta hand it to the Russo brothers this
is definitely an easter egg that I think
everybody missed I never saw it anywhere
online
I missed it myself personally nobody I
know caught this and nobody brought it
to my attention that is until the script
for Avengers in game came out not too
long ago just a few days ago I think but
it revealed a beta ray bill Easter Egg
in Avengers endgame so this Easter Egg
is when we see bad nebula for the very
first time in Avengers in game back in
2014 it's when good nebula and war
machine are on Morag and nebula says
we're not the only people looking for
the power stone in 2014
Rhodey asked who else is looking as she
says my father my sister and me it then
immediately cuts to a scene of her in
battle her and Gamora are leading Thanos
as army taking over another planet no
doubt that US is trying to eliminate
half of the population of this species
on this planet and they have to do it by
hand because he doesn't have any of the
Infinity stones yet and you could never
tell
by watching the scene in Avengers
in-game but the planet that they're
actually on is korben korben is the home
planet to the korbinites and if you
didn't know beta ray bill is a korbinite
so we literally have a scene in Avengers
in game where nebula and Gamora are on
the home planet of beta ray bill and
this is confirmed by the script for
Avengers endgame on page 63 of the
script it says bad nebula cuts down a
korbinite soldier with dual blades she
leads thanasis troops onward as they lay
waste to the korbinite homeworld so the
script confirms this is Corbin this is
the world to the korbinites and famous
army has just attacked it and laid waste
to it so it doesn't sound like they're
actually cutting half of the population
of the planet it actually sounds like
they're just eliminating all life on the
planet now it's not very hard to see how
Marvel is planning on setting up beta
ray bill for his MCU debut in the comics
the korbinites almost became extinct
when their galaxy exploded the remnants
of the korbinite race flood in a fleet
warship guarded by a sentient ship
called scuttlebutt and a dedicated
champion beta ray bill so there are two
ways that beta ray bills origin from the
comics ties into the MCU for one like I
said his race was almost extinct by a
galaxy exploding now clearly the MCU
doesn't just copy the story from the
comics they change things up a little
bit but it appears that the korbinites
will almost become extinct however it
will not be from a galaxy exploding it
will be from Thanos and his army
attacking his race and almost making
them extinct now this could almost be
just like when Thanos attacked Thor and
his people
Thanos managed to kill most of them but
some of them got away we could possibly
be seen the same thing here but the
korbinites Thanos will probably kill
most of them but maybe some of them get
away and one of the korbinites who will
definitely get away is beta ray bill and
another interesting thing is that in the
origins like I said beta ray bill is the
korbinites champion well beta ray bill
has already been a champion in the MCU
we know that at one point in time he was
the Grand Master's champion on Sekar we
know this because we saw a statue of his
head on the grandmasters Tower in thor
ragnarok but one thing that you have to
keep in mind is the order of events
because remember we are travelling back
in time in a
in game when nebula Gamora and fan oz
attacked korbinite that was in 2014 so
thor ragnarok took place years after
this already had happened so it seems
like what most likely happened is that
beta ray bill managed to get away but he
ended up on Sekar and his story from
there will probably be somewhat similar
to the Hulk's and Thor's he gets
captured once he gets to sack our heck
it was probably even a Valkyrie who
captured him he gets thrown into the
arena and wins and eventually becomes
the champion which is why we see a
statue of his head on the tower now beta
ray bill is scientifically altered he
was physically augmented and given the
attributes of an indigenous wild of
beasts so he's pretty savage and pretty
strong and he's also very smart he was
smart enough and strong enough to beat
Thor in the comics so he probably
managed to escape some car somehow and
that's most likely where we'll leave off
when we get introduced to beta ray bill
in the MCU now another thing that's
really interesting is how beta ray bill
could tie into Nova in the comics and
the Thanos imperative storyline beta ray
bill joins Nova now the possibility of
this happening beta ray bill and Nova
teaming up in the MCU is actually
probably really high and their stories
are probably going to be quite similar
the directors and writers from Avengers
endgame have already revealed this
alternate scene for Nova to appear in
Avengers in game that we never saw
basically what would have happened is
when Thanos decimated Xander there was
only going to be one survivor
Richard Rider since he was going to be
the only Zen darian who lived he would
have inherited the entire Nova force and
from there would be on his own but he
would know that Thanos was the one that
decimated his planet the same would
happen with beta ray bill if he was the
only survivor or one of the only
survivors he would know that Thanos was
the one who was responsible for
basically making his race extinct both
would want to go out and seek revenge on
Thanos which would make a lot of sense
and it's already been confirmed that the
writers and directors for Avengers
endgame tried to work beta ray bill in
the movie they ended up leaving him out
because there was just so many
characters already they didn't want to
introduce a major important character
and him not get a lot of time but we did
end up getting nebula and Gamora
on Corbin and the same goes for Nova
they wanted to introduce him and avenges
in-game but thought that it would just
be too much to introduce a brand new
character but the two of them could run
into each other when they're going
across the galaxy seeking revenge for
Thanos that is until they run into the
guardians of the galaxy and for who
state that Thanos is now dead and that's
where we could leave off with the
guardians of the galaxy and for now we
may be introduced to both of these
characters and guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 however they will most likely not
be in the movie for very long it makes
sense to introduce both of them
especially if the Guardians and Thor
come across them somewhere in the galaxy
because we know that Nova was originally
supposed to debut in the very first
guardians of the galaxy film but the
guardians are most likely going to go
back to Xander at some point in time
that's where they could meet Nova and a
beta ray bill if he's there with him but
we know that Thor isn't really going to
be in guardians of the galaxy vol 3 that
much Thor love and thunder will come out
way before guardians vol 3 comes out and
we know he's going to go his own way and
maybe he takes beta ray bill with him
that would mean we could actually get
introduced to beta ray bill before
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 comes out
the reason they most likely will not
have these characters be too involved in
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 is because
that movie will most likely introduce
Adam warlock now there's been a recent
plot leaked that talks about the same
stuff that we've been hearing for a
while now the sovereign had made Adam
warlock to destroy the guardians of the
galaxy but of course he's going to end
up turning and helping them and the
enemy of the movie is going to be the
High Evolutionary this seems to have
been James Gunn's as planned before he
was fired and rehired by Disney he made
Guardians volume 1 and Guardians volume
2 and was already signed up to do number
3 he's confirmed that the script has
been written for a very long time now
years now ever since before guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 came out he knew the
story and the direction that he wanted
to go and at the end of guardians of the
galaxy volume 2 he made sure to let us
know that Adam warlock was coming to
Guardians vol 3
however when Avengers endgame came out a
lot of people thought that the script
may have to change Gamora died and the
2014 Gamora is nowhere to be found and
Thor has joined the guardians of the
galaxy on their quest so a lot of people
were worried that James Gunn would have
to change his script to adjust to
everything
happened in Avengers in-game but
according to James Gunn he doesn't have
to change anything in a recent interview
he was asked if the events and Avengers
endgame would affect his script and if
he would have to change the script based
off of everything that had happened and
he said the script will change because
my scripts always keep changing up until
the moment I shoot them but it won't
change according to anything from
endgame because I already knew what was
in that script before I wrote guardians
3 so Marvel kept James Gunn in the know
which makes sense because Avengers
endgame had a lot of repercussions to it
but James Gunn already knew about all of
them when he wrote the script for
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 that means
he knew the current time Gamora would be
dead and he knew that Thor would be
joining the guardians of the galaxy that
means that unless James Gunn completely
decides to change the script we can
pretty much expect Adam warlock to
appear in guardians of the galaxy vol 3
which means that Nova and beta ray bill
if they are introduced in the movie
probably won't be in there for too long
beta ray bill will most likely be more
involved with Thor and Nova will
probably be in the movie for a little
bit but this will most likely be a setup
for his own film but let me know what
you think about this what do you think
about this beta ray bill Easter egg and
Avengers endgame and do you think that
eventually he will run into Nova do you
think beta ray bill escaped and managed
to make his way to Sekar and then escape
again and do you think that we'll see
Nova and beta ray bill run into the
guardians of the galaxy and Thor let me
know your thoughts about this in the
comments down below also don't forget to
like the video and subscribe with
notifications turned on so you can enter
my giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
one or a ps4 also don't forget to click
the link in the description down below
if you'd like a chance to win an
Infinity Gauntlet and don't forget to
use code cosmic at G feel calm for 30%
off your G feel as always thank you all
so much for watching
woof woof